l'ex dragon opération d'embarquer déjà
dit qu'on peut nourrir un adulte des
deux ados pour -75 leur part cela peut
vous en journée selon vous est ce que
c'est réel ensuite puis 61 $ d'épicerie
par semaine pour nourrir une famille
monoparentale avec deux adolescents ça
veut dire que chaque vote à woippy bien
moyenne droit dollars 57 doit dollars 57
pour un repas qui vont nourrir trois
personnes tous les nutritionnistes à qui
nous avons parlé nous ont dit que
c'était irréaliste break en mangeant des
pâtes sans sauce avec des légumineuses
et du mayet sans concerne un adulte et
deux ados vont tenir le coup un moment
mais à long terme ça va être répétitif
difficile à 75 dollars par semaine et
guay des adieux aux fruits et légumes
frais aux fromages aux poissons et à la
viande pour avoir une alimentation
nutritive
le dispensaire diététique de montréal
estime qu'un adulte avec deux ados doit
prévoir au minimum un panier d'épicerie
à 190 $ par semaine et à 190 $ par
semaine il faut être discipliné
planifient et cuisiner tous les repas ni
compris des collations
[Musique]